since the mid 20th century people had
been dreaming of making computers that
mimic the human mind by letting them
learn on their own from experience using
a new type of computer inspired by
biological brains known as neural
networks neural networks have remained a
more or less obscure corner of computer
science as they were conceived in the
1950s but since around 2009 due to a
rapid surge in computer power neural
networks are suddenly performing
functions we never thought possible
leading to a second computing revolution
we called deep learning traditionally in
the 20th century the approach to
computer design was to give them a list
of explicit human written instructions
to define their action a program
regardless of what these programs did
they were essentially sequences of
logical decisions however with neural
networks we throw away this human
centric view of programs instead of
having humans input explicit
instructions to define the behavior of a
computer the neural network learns
everything by itself using direct
experience starting with a random
connection pattern it gradually self
wires into parallel patterns of
computation in order to perform complex
functions automatically often achieving
human or superhuman performance on a
growing set of tasks which recently were
thought far out of reach of machines
let's look at a few practical problems
first to get a sense of this new power
take tic-tac-toe for example the board
is small and the length of the game is
short and so it's easy to make every
decision based on checking all future
moves until the game is over chess on
the other hand was much harder because
the board is bigger and the games are
much longer and so the number of
possible sequence of moves quickly
explodes easily greater than the number
of atoms in the known universe the only
way to play chess is to make short cuts
which take the form of best guesses
the chess masters described these moves
as feelings not calculations in the
1990s the deep blue computer developed
by IBM was programmed by asking the
chess champions for the logic behind
their strategies this led to sets of
rules which were connected together in a
huge step by step decision-making
algorithm which famously beat the chess
master Garry Kasparov but two people in
the computer science community this felt
more like a publicity stunt than a real
revolution it wasn't satisfying that a
machine following many thousand human
rules could do something about as well
as a single human can but compare that
to the recent deep learning approach
applied to chess instead of using human
design rules researchers throw away all
hard coded knowledge about chess and
gave the computer only the rules of
chess and let it learn the game of chess
entirely through self play starting with
a random strategy and feedback on wins
and losses it absorbed winning chess
strategies which were far beyond human
capability and it did this self learning
in a matter of hours and beat the human
design computer chess programs which
represented 30 plus years of expert work
and it keeps getting better
Kasparov called it alien chess because
it would think deeper and wider than a
human can
and today right now chess players and
masters all over the world are working
with these systems to learn new
strategies of chess never before seen
you know it's always fun to see someone
move something with a really
iconoclastic style so some of the things
that alpha zero is doing are just
incredible another example consider
translating between languages up until
recently computer translation was built
on huge look-up tables of lots of
existing translated text to reference
along with a huge web of rules for each
language at Google for example it was
developed with the involvement of
hundreds of human experts and linguists
this resulted in a complex translation
machine which worked for a word or two
but quickly broke down into gibberish
especially beyond a sentence
however compare this to the recent deep
learning approaches to translation where
researchers throw away all human design
knowledge instead they started from
scratch and exposed a neural network to
millions of examples of human translated
text and let it learn the translation
process on its own by absorbing the
patterns involved in translation and
rapidly the quality of the translation
system improved the word error rate on
simple translations dropped from 20% to
near 0% over the short term the power of
deep learning is even more apparent when
we look at intuitive problems by
intuition we mean actions we perform but
can't perfectly describe in words such
as the problem of recognizing a face
seeing a face is more of a feeling we
have difficult to explain in a sequence
of instructions this is why the idea of
a human writing a huge series of
instructions to recognize things and
images seem near impossible the best
minds working together on this problem
for over 50 years ended up with
algorithms which failed about a quarter
of the time useless for anything
practical especially critical
applications that was until people
flipped to the deep learning approach
and instead collected millions of
examples of images which already had a
human-made label and fed it into the
neural network at the level of
individual pixels to learn from using
the human provided labels as initial
feedback the network then absorbed the
statistical information in the images
from the pixels up and separated into
conceptual or word buckets where the
idea of a dog versus a cat comes down to
a unique pattern of activations inside
the network in 2012 this was famously
demonstrated with a huge breakthrough in
a computer vision competition called
image net where systems based on neural
networks suddenly cut the error rate
down by over 50 percent in one year and
within just a few years the machines
were superhuman at recognizing many
kinds of images so the field of image
diagnosis where we are looking for an
illness in an image had to adapt to this
new tool
which can often identify patterns that
humans can miss by now the trend should
be getting clear the old human
engineered rural systems would hit a
wall in performance while the deep
learning systems just keep improving
often beyond a human level but we've
only been looking at this from the
perspective of using neural networks to
analyze information but we can also run
them in Reverse to generate information
for example a network trained on lots of
human text can spit out random essays on
any topic which are difficult if not
impossible to distinguish from human
they were so good that the researchers
who first saw the results decided it was
best to hold the system back from the
public for fear it could be used to
generate fake but realistic information
of all kinds perhaps in ways they
haven't yet imagined the same thing
happened with images for example a
neural network which learned to
recognize faces can endlessly generate
new images of human faces that don't
exist as of today you can no longer
trust a photo or a video in the same way
so at first we will experience this new
computer revolution both by computers
which can trick us in ways like never
before but also fill in our blanks in
ways people have been dreaming about
since the dawn of computers it's the
computer science equivalent to the
realization that the earth isn't the
center of the universe where humans
aren't the center or upper limit of
intelligence and this advance really
breaks down into two key ideas we will
explore in this series the first was to
let machines learn knowledge instead of
hard-coding it into their instructions
known as the machine learning paradigm
every time he does something a little
closer to what we want him to do we
reinforce him twenty minutes and the
pigeon has learned affected this
and the second idea was to move away
from this idea of following a sequence
of instructions based on words and move
towards using parallel patterns of
activity as the unit of computation
known as a distributed representation
having a symbol only view of the mind
was described as the classic mistake by
Geoffrey Hinton who is known as the
father of deep learning in fact still
most people in AI they made a very naive
mistake which is they thought that
strings of symbols come in as words when
you say something strings of symbols
come out so they think what's in between
must be something like a string of
symbols even though you know that what's
in the brain is just big vectors of
neural activity
there's no symbols in there instead what
goes on inside the brain looks like it
happens at the level of patterns not
symbols these patterns take the form of
a cascade of electrical pulses which we
can see are unique to different thoughts
and that's not meant to be a joke that's
what I believe a thought is a thought is
an activity pattern in a big bunch of
neurons and only later in life do humans
start using symbols to express these
thoughts using language working at the
level of patterns of activations or
feelings first not symbols first this is
a biologically inspired view of thought
that neural networks exhibit it gives
machines what we call a sense of their
inputs or a form of intuition but of
course there are many limitations
concerns and open questions about
learning with neural networks and
parallel questions about how the brain
functions of which we have a very
limited understanding especially when it
comes to explaining what exactly makes
the human mind unique and so to begin we
need to go way back in time and think
about what we mean when we say
intelligence
[Music]
you